[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you
I mean he knows a lot about football but
if you sure have been wrong did I tell
you did I tell you about Kyle Allen big
win for the show a deep sleeper that
came through that's great dude big win
for the show you're the man baby week
four we got a whole season to go what we
got another show to do right now yeah
right now it's time for your fantasy
fire drill
[Music]
[Music]
and Caesars Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas
it's your fantasy fire drill and here's
your host
I'm clean now I got Gatorade in spots
you want to know about but that's not
important because it's time for your
fantasy fire drill I am at camp we are
live here in Las Vegas at Caesars at the
sports book as we are every single
Sunday 11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific as we
get you ready for week four and beyond
and I'll get to plenty of your questions
throughout the show and as soon as the
show is over I'll jump in the app where
you guys might be right now to get to
plenty more of your questions we're
gonna talk about the inactives there's
some late-breaking news there we'll give
you some sleepers and some adjustments
on the sleepers I'll take a Matz moment
as oh we always do and we'll get you
ready like I said for week four and
beyond so thanks for joining us here as
we always start the show with little
campfire talk where didn't we possibly
get that name from well the big story of
the week is the return of Melvin Gordon
to Los Angeles chargers and a lot of
people have been asking me for the last
couple days what do I do with Melvin
Gordon what about Austin Eckler this
feels like van Halen to me we have
multiple lead singers or do we who even
lead back for the Los Angeles chargers
well this is where we thought we were to
start the season right David Lee Melvin
Gordon but then he held out so Melvin
Gordon takes a seat who steps in but one
Austin Eckler and Austin Eckler has been
playing at a top five level sammy austin
Eckler whatever you want to call them
but austin Eckler has been the man for
the Chargers and he's been the man on
your fantasy team if you took a mess a
third running back but now we have both
players ready to go for today now I will
tell you this for week four which is
where we're at right now it is still
Austin hecklers show Austin Eckler is
still ranked in my top 5 this week
partially because while he's been
getting it done partially because he's
playing the Dolphins and also because
Melvin Gordon just came back now I
didn't think Melvin Gordon would be
active today but apparently he will be
why because Justin Jackson spoil earlier
on our ins and outs will not play today
so Melvin Gordon to me is a flex at best
if he scores a touchdown it's a bonus if
he gets 10 touches I think that's a big
win if you play him I don't expect that
to have
also they're playing the Dolphins so
they don't need to rush him back they
should crush the Dolphins today they got
a lot of injuries there it's still
Austin hecklers show for this week but
don't be surprised if things change in
the future
I will say Austin Eckler will still have
value
even if Gordon takes back over the lead
role so there you go
we did a bit there's the doorbell
[Applause]
charges I don't know if you got the
point there no Matt I don't think you
got the point there baby it's a football
Melvin Gordon it's still hecklers show
but I mentioned the ins and outs and
actives let's get to those right now as
we give you the most updated news we
have will update this again later on in
the show so you can make the proper
adjustments so here we go Mark Andrews
are not official and active out yet but
he is expected to play today students we
have it we will bring that to you
Devin Singletary for the Buffalo Bills
Bills do not have their inactives out
yet he is not expected to play I will
tell you this though about Devin
Singletary because he's not expected to
play and because the bills are playing
the Patriots I do like TJ Yeldon as a
deep sleeper in PPR formats moving on at
ey Hilton and he will not be out there
today now I'm gonna tell you I give you
a spoiler
jokowi Brissette is in the deep sleepers
but you got to move them down a little
bit with t white Hilton out today
unfortunately because of the injury that
listed him is doubtful Terry Maclaurin
is out today this is why you do not have
injury optimism Terry Maclaurin and was
oh it's a minor deal it's not that big
of a deal he is not in today we will not
see Terry Maclaurin we can follow by the
way up on Mark Andrews he will play
today so you continue to play him as a
top six tight end speaking of Maclaurin
by the way Richardson deep I do like
Vernon Davis as a top 12 tight end Rex
Burkhead here for the Patriots is
expected to play but it's up in the air
right now more of a game-time decision
I'm not that pumped about him anyway
because James White is back from the
baby that him and his wife had last week
now Edelman also expected to play
nothing official yet
got the chest injury I will say this
about Edelman they could be careful with
his snaps today and if they're up big
potential against the bills we didn't
see him play much the second half last
week could be the same thing then again
you could be a reason but the Patriots
go up on the bills Matthew Stafford is
playing through a painful hip injury but
he will play today this guy plays
through everything to his credit he's in
my top 15 a little concerned there
Edelman is active today we can give you
that update look at that live on the fly
Edelman will play today he is in my top
20 at wide receiver
now here's three players I could tell
you are out Damian Williams spoiler
we're gonna get to the other running
back there in Kansas City by the way
LeSean McCoy with his ankle injury was
off the practice report off the final
injury report I should say completely
he's not a hundred percent but he still
lead back for the Chiefs Mike Williams
and Justin Jackson for the charters
today are both out and I can tell you
this know hunter Henry as well you throw
that in there it's the reason I think
we're gonna see more of Gordon today but
we're still gonna see plenty of Austin
Eckler now the late-game inactives and
the injuries of note obviously we can't
necessarily completely lock these in
Rashad Penny's up in the air I know it's
well Karstens been fumbling they want to
stick with Carson especially with penny
banged up so I think penny you'll play I
don't have a lot of confidence in his
workload Chris Godwin is that a little
bit up in the air but he should be able
to play I did move him down a little bit
he's not inside my top 15 he's inside my
top 20 top 25 but I can tell you we know
this Michael Gallup will not play
against the Saints now I'll tell you
this I really liked what I saw from
Michael Gallup and I'm a believer in the
Cowboys offense I will tell you this
about Michael Gallup he's a good bi-lo
candidate if somebody's getting
frustrated with his extended absence ari
will update any other enactors we didn't
get to later on in the show but why you
tuned in you're looking for answers to
your questions for week four and beyond
let's get to those questions right now
let's see halls bf talk which Heisman
Trophy winner do I go with Lamar or
Kyler I'm all about Lamar Jackson you're
playing them until further notice Matt
Matt says Calvin Ridley or Terry
Maclaurin well we don't maclaurins out
so there's simply you just go right with
Calvin Ridley this week witness Mitton
Darryl Williams oh we might bring him up
Chris Godwin to Robert woods
I'll stay away from the injury with
Godwin and I'll play a Robert Woods
today next up here are K SSI trade
austin Eckler forsake one and mike
williams so you got a guy who's gonna
move down the depth chart personal depth
chart coming up later on in the show
trading for berkeley and for mike
williams i'm okay making that deal start
Marvin Jones or Phillip Lindsey I have a
little bit better feeling about Marvin
Jones in his matchup today I will play
him over Phillip Lindsey should I play
Mark Andrews or Hollywood Brown as my
Flex no anders is expected to play but I
love Hollywood Brown this week if you
want to go for the upside go ahead and
do so the Brown secondary is a mess now
we go to the board for a video question
hi Matt it's Jenny so I have a question
for you so with the way Daniel Jones and
how Allen produced last week do you
think we'd expect something similar from
Mason Rudolph thank you
love the open-mindedness when it comes
to quarterbacks if you went with me last
week you got Kyle Allen in your lineup
we saw what Daniel Jones did I'll bring
up him a little bit more in a little bit
Mason Rudolph and hasn't happened just
yet the connection with James White from
their college days hasn't really been
there and they do have the Bengals today
so if there's a this week I should say
if there's a time to somewhat get
interested in Mason Rudolph it would be
this week I'm not playing him but I will
keep an open mind if he does it against
the Bengals I wouldn't be shocked but
play those matchups when it comes to
quarterback so you can stream with a lot
of success and you might be doing it
with some of the players we bring up
right now because it's time for my
sleepers
so we go deep deep sleepies last week
all right Jason should add a touchdown
our single Whiteside should've had a
touchdown didn't happen we gave you Kyle
Allen we talked about Rex Burkhead as
well so who do we have for this week I
don't know if it's that deep because I
think this is America's running back
tight end I think this is North
America's tight and this might be the
world's tight end pick for the week it
is will dis Lee and he checks a lot of
boxes for you this week first of all
he's got the Cardinals the worst defense
against fantasy tight ends this season
so bad that the next Worst team is a
ten-point difference that's how many
points are being scored by tight ends
against the Cardinals number two he's
got multiple touchdowns in the last
couple weeks so he's playing well and OH
number three a little check mark mop
marked for him as well is the fact that
they traded Nick Vanette to the
Pittsburgh Steelers so it's all well dis
Lee you're playing them to me as a top
seven tight end this week moving on here
to our next sleeper and I told you a
little about this already so note ey
Hilton doesn't give me as much
excitement for jo koy Brissette he's my
number 15 quarterback he would have been
top ten if Hilton were to be out there
I've made that adjustment already so if
you need the top 15 quarterback he can
run the matchup is good against the
Raiders I will tell you this if you have
Daniel Jones and you're thinking about
that maybe with him maybe in your DFS
lineup
Daniel Jones is ranked higher so a
couple of quarterbacks that I do like
this week Jones if you read my sleepers
article was in there as well but not as
high on Jacoby Brissette knowing that's
ey Hilton is out this week now one more
and we're gonna go to Kansas City and
we're gonna tell you about Darryl
Williams now let me let me tell you
something I will admit things I was
wrong about Darwin Thompson last week
apparently the whole fantasy industry
was wrong about Darwin Thompson but we
don't and act stubborn we get things
right Darryl Williams is the guy with
LeSean McCoy no Damian Williams today
when in doubt go get a piece of a great
offense you're doing so with Williams
with the Chiefs and oh by the way he
played well last week I wouldn't be
surprised if he stuck around why I
warned you about Damien Williams before
the start of the season some sleepers
for this week I'll give you one more an
extra one
Vernon Davis with Terry Maclaurin out
Giants defense struggling so there you
go some deep sleepers for this week but
now
we get to more of your questions for
week 4 and potentially beyond desi says
James Connor or carry on Johnson
I see carrion is a little bit safer but
I liked James Connors upside against the
bangles moving on here jatt 2019 1 flex
spot Gordon Michelle John Brown or Ross
I'll play Josh Gordon this week assuming
it's Josh Gordon if it's not in the go
Sony Michelle a neat item worth trading
for on the low since position is
decimated retro maybe not a trade but
maybe you go hit your waiver wire for
Chris
Herndon who will come off a four-game
suspension after this week Robinson or
Hardman I assume those are both of the
chief receivers and I'll tell you to go
hard with me Cole Hardman Emperor should
I start rivers or Jones at quarterback
I love Philip Rivers this week why he's
playing the Dolphins even with all the
injuries there he's always made the
receivers around him much better salve
internal I started Jordan Howard this
week nice job Connor or Gordon is RB -
don't play Melvin Gordon is your RB to
play James Connor we help you out in the
app we help people out on video boards
and now I go out into the public I go
out here the sports book at Caesars I
was told this week with my good friend
McKenzie Mitchell I should put the mic
in my other hand so I'm gonna do so
right now we bring in our guest a
question here your name please sir Steve
Steve welcome in what's your question my
question is sit one start one Danny
dimes Jones or Philip Rivers Wow
a good spot to be in by the way good job
by the way hitting the waiver wire I
love rivers this week against the
Dolphins as much as you're a Giants fan
I don't think you could really go wrong
there so you get to watch Philip Rivers
do well and you'll also watch the annual
Jones do well good luck to you this week
I appreciate it thank you go there's our
question we got one in here from the
yeah what do you know okay I promise
it's fantasy football related
okay so if Patrick mahomes was a van
Halen song what song would he be jump
let's thinking hot for teacher
I've never been happy you're gonna have
piano music at the time for a matte
moment
like sandwiches cheesesteak grilled
cheese I want to say top five sitcoms no
friends was I doing there besides I
don't know trying to figure out my life
I was assessing my personal depth charts
and other things in my life but we're
talking about your fantasy depth charts
it's time to reassess those we're three
weeks into the season I want you to take
everything from your draft and throw it
out the window
I don't care who you took in the first
round versus the ninth round because
guys like Hollywood Brown who's in my
top 20 this week may not have even been
drafted maybe they were your fifth
receiver and now you're starting them as
a wide receiver to this week maybe
you've lost confidence in Aaron Jones
because for some reason the Packers
don't want to run the ball at the goal
line and you moved him down your board
maybe you don't feel good about Baker
Mayfield I get that Lamar Jackson might
have been your QB too and he's now one
of the best quarterbacks in all of
fantasy football
we're three weeks into the season I
don't care where are you drafted players
if they were sleepers if they were
cornerstone players you assess your
personal Jeff chart accordingly if you
don't have as much confidence in a guy
maybe he's down to your Flex don't stick
with what you did in the draft assess
your personal depth chart and continue
to do so each and every week that's been
your mat moment for a week for more of
your questions though
right now let's see what we're trying to
get everybody ready as much as we can
Lucca McCoy dak or Russell Wilson I
don't mind dak against the Saints but I
love Russell Wilson against the
Cardinals one of the worst defenses in
football wired Duke Johnson's carries
being decreased here's the thing I'm not
surprised by this he's never had more
than 104 carries in a season so he's
always been a flex player to me at best
maybe the Houston Texans screwed up by
how much they gave up to get him trade
Melvin Gordon 40y Hilton and James White
that's not bad I just hate trading into
injury situations so I don't think I
would make that deal next question here
Jay Roselle OH Olson or dis Lee I have
Olson that thicket four or five dis
Lee's at seven great spot to be in
you may have a trade to make I would
trade well this Lehi Freeman or Peterson
assuming that's Devonta Freeman I would
play him in fact I'd probably play Roy
stream in over Adrian Peterson as well
next one here trade Gulman for Eckler
that's a move I believe it or not would
make because I still think even after
this week Austin Eckler will have solid
flex value now typically this is where
we go to a celebrity question or a
bleacher report question from one of our
personalities but instead I have to
bring this up I was invited to a
tailgate and I was told they would have
to let's find out this stupid tailgate
meal hey Steve hater here yeah I know it
looks like I'm in a bordello I'm not or
or maybe I am but alright so the
question you have for me is is soup a
tailgate meal look I think I you know
where I'm gonna go with this okay but
I'll be specific no it's not a tailgate
meal because one you can for a meal you
need a knife or a fork right well then
you may say what about a sandwich how
about your hands okay fine a knife a
fork or your hands can you do soup with
any of those no you cannot so there's
your answer no soup is not a tailgate
meal now can I get back to the bordello
thank you thanks to Steve Kenny Bank I
saw Seinfeld like feet away last night
there's the real star of the show he's
telling you about soup and the man knows
about soup being a meal or not I will
tell you one thing Kenny Cooper cup I
was get questions at him soup goes in a
cup
Cooper cup Steve PPR gold Steve pp our
goal thanks to Steve for your question
now we get back to your inactives
because we have some updated information
in fact we got them all updated now okay
we can tell you Mark Andrews is good to
go for today I know he's playing to the
foot injury he's still a top six option
at the position Devin Singletary is
officially out kind of like that he's
sitting out this week anyway because
they're taking on the Patriots TJ Yeldon
a deep sleeper with Buffalo likely
playing from behind
unfortunately t white Hilton is out
today as I said we've downgraded one
Jacoby Brissette just a little bit there
although it's still a good matchup
against the Raiders Terry Maclaurin is
out today I'm not super high on Paul
Richardson
but I do like Vernon Davis as a top 10
option at the Titans
and Rex Burkhead will play I will say
this don't get too excited about him
because James White is back this week I
think that was a bigger deal for Burkett
and the Patriots were not happy with how
they ran the ball last week Patriots
backfield
once again the Bellatrix have returned
Julian Edelman is in there talking about
careful with the snaps
I think the scoreboard will be part of
that as well when they take on the bills
today I'm still playing him as a top 20
wide receiver Mathew Stafford's got a
bad hip he's gonna play through that
injury
just outside my top 12 not obviously
ideal circumstances with a hip but the
guy plays through everything and then
three players we know are out Damian
Williams out we made our correction
Darryl Williams is a nice flex play for
this week by the way McCoy came off the
final injury report not a hundred
percent with the angle ankle but he's
still a top twenty option Mike Williams
and Justin Jackson are definitely out
for the Chargers I think Melvin Gordon
is ok as a flex it's still Austin
hecklers show i ranked them as a top 3
tight end for this running back for this
week now late games what we know Rashad
Penny up in the air right now I still
think it's Chris Carson show I'd really
like it Chris Carson if you could hang
on to the football
we'd all appreciate that Chris Godwin a
little bit up in the air I think he's
gonna be able to go is outside my top 15
this week but we do know Michael Gallup
will not play against the Saints he is a
good buy low candidate I got a lot of
questions in but we're gonna get a lot
more in now cuz it's time for the speed
round
[Music]
coach I think we're getting through a
bunch of these I have my headband on
where it is if I break the record today
you will get a rate I need one I deserve
one I'll buy you all the soup you want
can you beat 15 yes I could do it let's
do it with your support I could do it
let's get these questions in can we get
to 15
from Kevin 12-team PPR Derrick Henry er
carry on Johnson Derrick Kennedy's in my
top 10 this week you play him against
the Falcons Ethan and Godwin or Waller
if you want to just avoid the injury and
play Waller with the one o'clock game
Tennessee's a Western game you can go
ahead and do so Walker additionally I
have Walker one spot higher then will
this Lee so we're gonna go with Walker
for this week from Enrique next question
here number four Todd Gurley or three
Colin come on now you're still playing
Todd Gurley even if he's not a top ten
option play Todd Gurley this week Dre
day should I trade Tyreke Hill for
Lindsey and Kirk if you need help right
now and you're like oh and three I'm
okay making that move but if you're
three no I would stay put with Tyreke
he'll next one here should I train Julio
for dak Prescott and Mike Evans I'm
gonna tell you to go with Mike Evans and
dak Prescott because you're getting a
somewhat similar receiver back and a
quarterback if you D when I'm okay with
that trade start Nick Chubb or Marlon
Mac I would go with I think I would go
with Nick Chubb there but just by a
little bit next one here let's go to
keep the Titans defense or go with the
Broncos Titans against the Falcons and
we're halfway there I just bought a new
car that's how confident okay gotcha
Titans defense against the Falcons is
okay to go with their next one here to
quarterback League Josh Allen daniel
Jones for Russell Wilson I would sit
Josh Allen down against the New England
Patriots next one Shepherd fits her
cooks I always like cooks we're gonna
play him and I'm gonna tell you to play
Shepherd over Fitz today
I love the upside against the terrible
Washington Redskins deep
DJ war or Robert Woods love woods today
when a doubt I typically go with my Rams
next one keep it going
we're up to 12 Darryl Williams Chris
Thompson LeSean McCoy McCoy is your safe
play there I think I would stick with
him he's still the lead guy for the
Kansas City Chiefs Emmanuel Sanders rdk
Metcalf as a flex Sanders is probably
the safe play if you want to go for some
free supreme upside go with Metcalf
against the terrible Cardinal secondary
Curtis Samuel or Darryl Williams at Flex
I liked our Williams today very simply
because he's on the Chiefs it's a great
offense keep it going here who day all
day should I bench digs John Brown or
Montgomery to get Olson in my lineup
I would bench John Brown against the
Patriots Bill Belichick targets best
players I think he will take out John
Brown today Danny dimes are Tyler Murray
close but I'm gonna play pile of Murray
against Seattle Seahawks OB facility
isn't that good we did it
coach we did it I got you a present
doing all that extra money it's a
wristband Oh Lisbon okay you're getting
arrays and hopefully you learned
something hopefully you got your
question answered if you didn't I'm
jumping in the app for the next 25 30
minutes were sort of get any other
questions that I didn't get to remember
my big board comes out on Wednesdays you
get the app mailbag on Fridays to get my
sleepers article on Fridays and I'm here
every single Sunday at the sports book
at Caesars at 8:30 Pacific 11:30 Eastern
we get you ready each and every week
right here on your fantasy fire drill
you